Rebels the Epicurean charitable
Foundation is getting ready for its
annual event it's called menus 22
Casablanca Gala joining us here in the
kitchen to tell us more is Jason Wade
from breakthrough beverage Nevada Jason
good to have you with us this year's
event is actually going to feature
headliner of Big Bad Voodoo Daddy that's
correct yeah it's going to be an amazing
event uh we're going to be featuring at
the Zillow pool at the Sahara this year
we've got about 30 local restaurants
queued up some amazing wines some
amazing Spirits some cocktails it's
going to be incredible weather we're
teed up to have a great evening and it's
for a great cause too these are for
scholarships right absolutely so the ECF
focuses on providing full ride
scholarships for local students here in
the Las Vegas area to UNLV for the uh
for the hospitality school so we uh we
have an amazing board of directors that
provide mentorship to these students
along the way you know our board spans
just about every Avenue of the of the
hospitality and food and beverage
business so we really do what we can to
put some kids off on the right foot and
succeed in our industry again Jason this
hits close to home for you because this
is how you came through UNLV into the
hospitality you worked with Cosmo and
now with breakthrough so this makes
sense to you absolutely you know I'm
alumni of UNLV and uh probably so and uh
glad to Shepard the next generation of
students through the University where
can people get tickets uh you can buy
tickets on ecf.com
Epicurean charitable Foundation as our
website okay so you got Big Bad Voodoo
Daddy right yep uh what else can people
expect at the event uh well when you uh
when you arrive at the vent you'll be
greeted with uh several cocktail options
uh we've got great sponsors from Tito's
Handmade Vodka we've got Hendrix Jan
we've got a ton of great wines from all
over the world and some amazing
restaurants from within the Sahara on
the strip and a lot of local restaurants
as well so yeah a lot of great choices
you prepped this ahead of time right
this uh cocktail what'd you put together
for I got a little head start on this
side I'm not not a mixologist by trade
but uh this will be one of the cocktails
featured the event it's called the
Tangier Spritz because our theme this
year is Casablanca so we're going to
have everything kind of rolling in with
the theme so I love a good Spritz this
one starts with Tito's Handmade Vodka a
little bit of citrus in there this time
we're doing a little tangerine and lemon
we're doing a little uh strawberry
liqueur and then I like to top off any
Spritz with a good sparkling wine you
can do any kind of a Prosecco you can do
a little bit of club soda if you want to
kind of dial back the alcohol a little
bit good to give that a little bit of a
stir
and then a tire for the night what can
people uh attire for the night along
with the uh Casablanca theme where we'd
love to see everybody show up in white
and gold so okay something that goes
along with the theme for the evening so
if you want to if you want to dive in
and show up and show up let's see some
whites wear golden knights gear yeah we
can do that too but probably a little
more uh a little more we like to see a
little more formal though all right
Jason thanks so much good luck with the
event this week again people can get
tickets where all right Epicurean
charitablefoundation.com excellent we'll
have a link to that on our side as well
appreciate you being here we will be
right back